This misconception stems primarily from the
fact that, originally, aerosol cans used chlorofluorocarbons
as a propellant.
Chlorofluorocarbons were also used commonly
in refrigerators, air conditioners, and for
many industrial applications.
Chlorofluorocarbons were particularly popular
because they are non-flammable, non-toxic,
and non-reactive to most compounds.
However, after scientists began to observe
that the Earth’s ozone layer was thinning
beyond normal seasonal variations, in 1974,
Nobel Prize winner Dr. F. Sherwood Rowland
and Dr. Mario Molina discovered that these
chlorofluorocarbons were the likely cause
of the damage to the ozone layer, though this
wasn’t conclusively proven until 1984.
Despite the lack of conclusive evidence, in
the mid-1970s most manufacturers voluntarily
stopped using chlorofluorocarbons.
Further, in 1978, chlorofluorocarbons were
officially banned in the United States, with
a few exceptions.
These exceptions were primarily concerning
certain medical applications, such as with
asthma inhalers (though use in inhalers and
other medicinal applications were officially
banned in 2008).
Other countries quickly followed the U.S.
in banning the use of chlorofluorocarbons,
including Canada, Mexico, Australian, and
many European nations.
Thanks to the Montreal Protocol agreement,
ratified by 70 countries initially and 196
countries to date, production of chlorofluorocarbons,
along with other ozone damaging substances,
began to be phased out altogether starting
in 1996, the completion of which, even in
many developing countries, took place in 2010.
So the bottom line is that for the last three
decades or so in the U.S., followed by many
other developed countries shortly thereafter,
aerosol sprays haven’t contained any known
ozone depleting substances.